Chris the story of the week last week
the story of the week this week and
probably the story of the season will be
Antonio Brown he's gone from the Raiders
he'll officially signed with the
Patriots today yep you were in New
England as well we sure do what did you
even do there that's what they put on
that's what I felt like it was that's
what I that's your title
I was offensive quality control and then
was in charge of like some soms duties
scouting duties you know they kind of
make you do two for the price of one in
New England which was great experience
because you get to see all facets of
really how the organization works and I
think they want to see which way you're
gonna be more inclined yeah inside of
the front office yes definitely
definitely right it was neither some
water okay but you were there for 18
months right you you know what it's like
there yes Antonio Brown is walking
through that door today to sign a
contract right is it gonna work will he
be there when the playoffs roll around I
do think it's gonna work I think
everybody just needs to get used to it
oh I'll say this at the very least -
it's not gonna blow up in New England's
face okay
so there's a there's a floor there that
that I wouldn't be scared about if
you're a New England fan or anybody like
that because as soon as they get an
inkling of ooh this is not manageable
they will just say see you later as we
saw last night they don't need him to
win football games or for Tom Brady to
throw for 300 yards but that's the most
humbling place in all of football
because if you walk in there as a star
doesn't matter if you're Randy boss or
Antonio Brown Chad Ochocinco you walk in
and you go whoo this regime doesn't need
me and that checks your ego at the door
right away plus it's just all business
all the time there in New England
there's no like oh hell yeah this is
cool oh yeah we're here and it's
Wednesday and we're all laughing and
having a good time because we're playing
football when you walk in the door
during the day in New England it is work
as soon as you crossing that door and I
do think it'll work because of not only
Belichick but just the culture around it
and then having a great leader like Tom
Brady to help kind of massage things
along as well I don't see it being a bad
thing remember when reg
Wayne went to New England and exited
quickly yeah it's not fun yeah right
it's an and we've heard that from time
to time it's not a stop for everybody
what's fun is winning the Super Bowl
what's fun is showing up at Robert
crafts house to get your neck string
that's where the fun is and for Antonio
Brown hey he's had his eight months of
fun or whatever you'll want to call it
and he's gonna have to conform quickly
and and he'll see we talked during the
show about Bill Belichick ripping into
Tom Brady in front of guys like Chad
Johnson Randy Moss Donte Stallworth the
message it sends to them without him
having to rip them right he rips Tom
Brady the greatest of all time and it
shows everybody's in play everybody's in
play right the rules apply to everyone
but even with that knowledge can Antonio
Brown follow the rules is he capable of
showing up on time is he capable of
paying attention in meetings is he
capable of being anyone other than a B I
I don't know that is really the
million-dollar question ah I would hope
this at the very least he realizes this
is his last straw like I would hope he
realizes that if he messes this up and
most of the NFL if they see won't know
England couldn't handle him and couldn't
have Daft him to their culture then he's
gonna be out of football in general and
business will not be booming he will not
be making cash or anything like that so
it is a big question mark for a guy
where you know I do I worry about the
guy a little bit with some of the things
that have gone on on and off the field
lately just seems like he's lost lost
his way to a degree and hopefully New
England is the kind of place that can
refocus him there but yeah that's the
big question of whether he can conform
I'm gonna say he can just because of the
desperation he needs the money and also
the fact that he's got a guy like Tom
Brady around him who's a really
phenomenal leader I'm just fascinated by
how Bill Belichick will try to implement
this will he try to use the Jedi mind
trick where Antonio Brown comes to
conclusions on his own that Bill
Belichick wants him to come to or will
Bill Belichick have that heart to heart
saying Antonio I don't know how they do
things in Pittsburgh and I don't care
but we've won six superb
since 2001 and there's a reason for that
yeah there's a way that things are done
here and if you do them you'll be here
and if you don't you won't and it's that
simple I know I don't know if that'll
work on I don't even know if he'll
address it that way
I don't even know if he will I think he
almost will be one of those things where
it's like Jedi mind-trick like I'm gonna
pay you no attention almost right and
there's 53 other guys here 52 other guys
here other than you and I'm gonna treat
you exactly the same way and I just
think he's gonna learn kind of just from
being there and the way things are said
in meetings and then when they have a
team meeting and coach Bella checks in
front of the team he's gonna realize
that whew you know this ain't Kansas
anymore this is not Pittsburgh or or
Oakland to where you know they enable
their stars a little bit or placate to
them but what happens when he gets in
trouble for something and he doesn't
like it yeah and he posts something on
my face as belcheck would call it and
acts out right how do they deal with him
that I don't think there'll be any
dealing with him they will get rid of
him they will if he's not doing who
makes him understand that that he
doesn't have that that opportunity that
he has one chance
- sounds so weird I hope Drew Rosenhaus
is making him explain that to him at
least that's what he should be doing
it's hard for me to explain this then
this might sound weird but it's truly
like one of those things Mike you feel
it when you walk in the building there
you just go I was with three different
NFL teams I've been around football my
whole life my first day on the job there
I was like whoa this is like the most
uncomfortable like uptight like whoa
we're going to work and we're gonna
grind it out and it was March and I was
like holy cow what's this place gonna be
like in August you truly it like just
seeps out through the building there and
I I'm really think that's gonna be the
big thing more than anything he's just
gonna realize it's no nonsense from the
get-go and nobody's gonna like have
little special conversations with him
off in the corner bill might come up to
him during stretching you know before
pre practice just to have a little
banter with him but he's not gonna be
like hey you okay you okay oh you're my
guy I'm gonna get you the ball this week
oh no it's not that
Jon Gruden that's gonna go1 he's just I
really think it's almost like osmosis
once you get in that building
hey I it does make sense shockingly and
and I really don't know what's gonna
happen I want to see how the contract is
structured because even though we get a
9 million dollar signing bonus if I'm
the Patriots I defer the actual payment
as long as I can like right because it's
easier to get it back from him if you've
never paid it right right right so you
can minimize the damage because you give
9 million and see and I think part of
this is they are going to play to his
ego to a certain extent because I first
thought if the Patriots gonna touch him
it was gonna be a minimum salary deal
with huge incentives you have to be here
you have to prove it you know per game
roster bonus you're gonna you're gonna
get paid as you go but they knew he was
upset because of what happened in
Oakland they took away his guaranteed
money so what do they do they give him
guaranteed money right out of the gate 9
million signing bonus takes one edge off
of right and and and you know what if he
has a big year they he makes fifteen
million half of the thirty back and he
becomes a free agent next year and he
makes the other right they'll probably
give them the other 15 next year if it
works out this year's got the incentive
to do it I part of me wants it to work
part of me wants it to be a disaster
because it's a great story as long as
it's a disaster it's a great ski there I
think either way it's gonna be a great
story I mean if he leads the league in
receiving and touchdowns we're all gonna
go this is unbelievable story what a
year my big thing is this when do you
think Antonio Brown knew he wanted out
of Oakland and wanted to make a move to
go to the New England Patriots cuz I
don't think this was like oh I got
released let me call teams now and
figure out when do you thinking well I'm
just spitballing it never worked in
Oakland for a variety of reasons the
whole thing with the frozen feet and the
helmet kept it from ever really meshing
right last Wednesday when he got that
letter from mike Mayock that's when he
was done with the Raiders now at some
point between Wednesday and Saturday I'm
do you think happens days letter do you
think it was Wednesday do you think it's
Wednesday's letter that you didn't think
it was like I apologized to the team and
then he found out that his guarantees
were voided no you think it was the
letter itself Wednesday's loaded at the
moment he put that thing on social media
when he implemented his plan to get the
hell out of Oakland and look everybody
knew that the Patriots are interested in
him back in March but that the steel
weren't gonna trade him to anyone in
their division or the Patriots so this
is the roundabout way this is the Brett
Farve de Minnesota by way of the Jets
without actually playing for the Jets
that's what Antonio Brown pulled off
I've told you before I mean this guy at
base level looks crazy but he also might
be crazy smart to pull some of these
things off because I I know I told you
this before and one of the reasons I
know in Pittsburgh they had an inkling
that something was gonna go down because
he is he had told somebody there who has
told me you know I'm a businessman first
I love football but I'm a businessman
first so that tells you he's very aware
of that aspect of the game and always
trying to kind of stay one ahead and in
the chess match of business in the NFL
we will find out soon
whether Antonio Brown is crazy like a
fox or just crazy yeah we'll know we'll
know by Halloween yes
don't you think I'd would think so yes
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports